do you want no it's Nadia true every
teen show the teen show miss me lad
hamdulillah assalamualaikum that's
degrading a peace peace be unto you we
are those people those that have come to
a conscious decision that there's only
one God one God not three and one God is
not to be divided he is one we have come
to that decision that we're going to
worship Him alone we're going to
establish the prayer five times a day
we're going to fast during a month of
Ramadan we're going to pay there's a cot
the poor do and we're going to dedicate
to making the Hajj at least once in our
life where physically and financially
able to how do we come to this we use
good old common sense we use the tools
that the creator of the heavens the
earth has given us so when we done this
now we have used this and we've come to
this truth we want other people to be
able to come to the same truth the same
realization that we've come to along
with the knowing and being totally
without any shadow of doubt knowing who
our Lord is and now at the same time
knowing that he sent a messenger and
this messenger is not one who is living
today he was living 1400 years ago and
he wasn't sent for a particular time as
Jesus was as Moses was as Abraham we
don't have their teachings even if we
wanted to follow them we could not it
wasn't meant for us to follow them the
messenger that is meant for us to follow
today if you're living is the Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
you don't want to just take my word for
it so we're going to have analysis of
his life so you can be convinced like
over 1.5 billion people in the world are
today so my next guest comes out it's
already natural that you believe in one
God and you worship Him alone you don't
worship a man
ki an elephant nothing in the creation
but the create tour but now you might
have some damn I know this man Mohammed
was a prophet how do I know Eddie talk
to me so that's what we're going to be
covering today all we ask is that you
have open heart open mind and my next
guest will clear up any doubts that you
might have with my next guest here on
the Dean she'll be right back Allah
there's only one word is his messenger
Allah
ha there's only one where Jesus was his
messenger Allah no I did that may be it
may be just the break the ice assalamo
alaikum assalaam o Allah peace be unto
you Anna how's it going everything is
hundred percent now translate you said I
Philomath sudden we have a lot of
non-muslims would you say I know son and
it's a very nice greeting it's an Arabic
greeting l his family yeah and saddle is
easy and simple and relaxed so when you
tell someone adeline was I then you're
really saying that you know your family
and the dealings between us and the
interaction is easy and it's relaxed so
that's what is that I hope everybody at
home is relaxed you know a lot of times
you know with the media and the hype
don't believe the hype people are out
there thinking that you need to be tense
around Muslims that's true but we're
striving for peace you know interesting
one time it was this was many years ago
and Halloween was on a Friday yeah and
so I was wearing my throat nose going to
jummah uh-huh it was his old lady
walking her dog she saw me she said oh
you're starting early she thought was my
Halloween oh but now let's uh let's
address that for a second I mean for
some people again they see you in what's
called a foe is this if you want be a
Muslim do you have to wear this oh you
don't have to do is no official Islamic
attire or yeah or national attire or
anything like that you know you can wear
whatever you want to wear you can wear a
thug like this and you can wear jeans
and shirt or a suit and tie or whatever
it is you want to wear you know so long
as you know it's not revealing in and of
itself there's no nothing that's
prohibited as in the material in itself
it doesn't resemble like women's
clothing and women don't wear anything
that resembles men's clothing besides
that it's very lacks it's not as strict
as most people might imagine it yeah to
be have you had any body like give you a
hard time say why are you wearing that
no no everyone else is wearing you know
jeans and sweatshirt this and why are
you wearing this weird america no I'm
first of all I don't I don't just like
this all most of the time but
when I do I never meet anyone who is
nasty and I have to have it to people
very civilized very well mannered one
time I was at a restaurant I was dressed
like this and a woman came to me she
said are you a rabbi so yeah I'm a black
rabbi but otherwise there are no
problems so this is just now this is
comfortable some modest way of dressing
but you can wear it like that you can
wear it like this as long as you're
dressing modestly yeah it's not
absolutely okay so we just got that
coffee scene you'll be learning
something already here on the Dean show
and but the main topic here today is the
genuine profit is the last and fundament
we say the last cent final master
problem on peace and blessings be upon
him solutely how does one come to the
realization that he is indeed a
messenger from the crater how's that
it's got to be easy first of all let's
get this straight it has to be really
easy to tell if Islam is a true religion
or a fake religion and it has to be real
easy to see which religion on earth is
the one from Allah and which is the one
for men from Devils from con man what
have you if I were to tell you Eddie I'm
going to give you ten essays one of them
is by Shakespeare nine are written by
kindergartners are you gonna is it going
to take you a long time to determine
which is very easy yeah you're not going
to be convinced I can't I can't see if
it's this one about me and mommy playing
in the park or if it's this one about
aww hello or whatever it is you can
easily tell all this is one that's why
stand for and what we're trying to say
is well a matter o Allah we don't like
it a lot to his creation but it can't be
that the one true religion from Allah
that's generally from God is going to
look exactly and not discernible from
the one that's from Devils one that's
written by men or made up by men or
altered by men and I can't tell which is
the one authored by Allah and which is
the one offered by the devil it can't be
or by people it can't be so you have
those that are altered by man that are
by the devil's this is so you have
though there were some religions that
gen that originally and genuinely came
la and then people all turn them change
the books change the scripture then you
have other religions that were just
totally made up by some guy and you can
even trace to the history to the guy who
made it up and the process that he went
to and then there are things that have
been distorted here and there so you can
easily tell which one is from a law
which isn't it has to be like that you
know what we're going to do in this
episode it started off I was in this was
again many many years ago and I was a
young man and there was this this Muslim
man he want to get married to a girl she
was an atheist right and you can't marry
an atheist he has to be Jewish or
Christian or Muslim to marry so he said
can you prove to her that God exists
that Allah exist I said if she's willing
to listen inshallah that's easy to prove
look it can't be hard to prove that
Allah exist it can't be it's got to be
one of the most easy thing easiest of
things to prove all right yeah so I said
if she's willing to listen shut law we
can do that God willing yeah so
basically we sat down and through
analyzing the life of the prophet saw
said them she was convinced that there
was a crate analyzing the life of the
process Edna so you didn't get into
something out you went straight to we
didn't talk about us yeah exactly yeah
yeah okay we're going to pick your brain
on this a little bit more we come back
absolutely break let's throw it back on
a disha it comes to you the truth and
the attribute of the one who created you
that he's one and alone running this
universe that he doesn't become bored he
doesn't die he doesn't eat and go to the
bathroom this is not God problem cares
yeah is this doesn't make sense who was
Jesus worshipping business is recorded
in the Gospels despite all of the other
issues about the Gospels we put those
aside to say expansion there that Jesus
worship God one
that's from hunger so talk to us now
tell us share this experience with this
woman that you went and she was an
atheist and then you went and talked to
about the problem having peace be upon
him and convinced her that there's a
creator and that obviously after that
that he is a messenger yes and it's a
very simple process yeah imagine any
right now as we're sitting here a guy
walks into the studio and he says hey
I'm a prophet of allah i was sent by God
how many questions would you need to ask
him I mean realistically you don't have
to ask him anything because we know
there's no other prophet but if you
didn't know that how many questions
would you have to ask him before you
could determine if he was speaking the
truth or he was an imposter not many at
all right certain questions would ask
like for example what is the most
important message in your religion if he
doesn't say it's about worshipping Allah
then definitely we can already put and
you know at first strike against him
worshipping God on my decorator because
every one of the prophets called people
to worshipping Allah alone yeah I mean
you look at this in the Old Testament
and you even look at it in the New
Testament everyone Moses said hear o
Israel the Lord our God is one Lord
right it's Anna 10 commandments Jesus
came and said the exact same thing it
word for word but there's only one God
worthy of worship the prophet muhammad
saw said of them said the exact same
things so if someone comes in today and
you tell them what's the most important
message what's the first commandment and
it's not that that's the first strike
against somebody's probably a liar
another thing we might ask okay what's
who is the angel that comes to you we
know that the angel that brings the
message to all the prophets of allah and
the messenger is the angel Gabriel zebra
a Gabriel orgy breathe yeah and if he
tells you well it's another angel his
name is you know you know mikail or mesu
then you know immediately that's another
X against him and this is one of the
things if you look at you know the
founder of the Mormon faith Joseph Smith
that's the first strike against him
because he didn't get a message from
gibril who did he meet he met according
to them the father and the son came down
in person that's never happened to
anybody this manjar quote unquote but it
happens to him so that's the first
strike against him he went outside of
the mold of what the prophets of Allah
went so he's discredited right off them
absolutely but there's another strike
actually many strikes again but another
very clear is he was 14 when that
happened you know since when does God
and according to them both God heads
which we don't believe that there are
two god there's only one God came to
this fourteen-year-old kid you know that
immediately that's another strike it
doesn't fit the mold of the prophets it
doesn't fit the stories of all the
prophets what they go through being
shepherds being Carpenters there's kids
suddenly you know sees God even though
jesus said no man has seen God at any
time nor heard his voice nor seen his
shape that's the contradiction so he has
to fit the mall of a prophet now with
the prophet muhammad sallallahu said
them which means may allah extol and
send blessings of peace upon him with
the prophet salallahu said then we have
every detail of his life the direction
he combed his hair would shew he put on
first which should we took off first you
know every detail how he relieved
himself what side he slept on how he put
his hand when he slept every detail of
his life is there is there anyone that
has more details of their life preserved
Bush Clinton michael jackson michael
jordan any of their lives detailed like
this man nobody in the history of human
some miracle itself is yeah and no
follower of any other prophet could
follow them to the smallest degree as we
can follow the Prophet salah salem so
now with all this information available
to us it would be easy for us to go and
look into it and look at his actions his
sayings his teachings his demeanor his
behavior his manners and see was this
genuine profit it was just some guy
pretending to be a problem because we
have so much information we can analyze
it and come to a clear conclusion true
or false true okay but before we do that
they're a bunch of other things first of
all let's assume because there are only
two options alright so this man mohamed
salah salem 1400 years ago came in
arabia and either he was a genuine
prophet given a message by Allah or he
was god forbid an imposter totally made
it up these are the only two options
yeah even if you say no maybe he really
cared about people and made it all up
for the sake of helping still means he
was not genuinely sent by Allah yeah he
made it up so the first thing we need to
discuss what would
the motive of this man why would he do
that like when the police they're
looking for a motive exactly crime
what's the motive behind him making this
guy mean that's what they look for they
look for the murder weapon they look for
the motive yeah no it doesn't work with
with with one of the two yeah so what's
the motive because we need a motive and
a strong one because he knows he lives
in Arabia he knows these Arabs they
fight over horses a horse race can start
a war that will go on for decades you
know so he knows that if he's going to
attack the most beloved things to them
their idols they're gonna fight against
him yeah so he must have a strong motive
to want to face years of battle and
warfare and attempted assassinations so
the motives now and yell here anyone can
put any motive they want to imagine
right so maybe he did this is now we're
talking about the assumption or at the
accusation of him making it up yeah why
would he make it up maybe he wanted
money so we put that down as a motive
maybe he wanted women yeah we put that
down as a motive maybe he wanted power
maybe he wanted Fame maybe he was ill he
heard voices and that prompted him to do
all these things whatever it is and
whatever like if you're asking some
water possible motives whatever they say
write it down whatever they say write it
down one time someone told me maybe he
was from outer space I wrote it down
yeah and then went to come back to when
and adeline analyzed his life his
teachings his sayings his manners his
mannerisms to see could it be that he
did it for money could it be that he was
from outer space whatever it is because
we can come to a clear conclusion that
he was a genuine profit by doing this
analysis so i'll give you one example
okay so we said maybe he pretended to be
a prophet because he wanted money yeah
right so now we have so much detail
about his life let's analyze we go back
to that now I've had authentic
information there you go I mean it was
it was detailed it was written in detail
everything that he did how he spoke how
we walked what he looked like physically
now we can go back and analyze it right
so if we accuse him of wanting money he
did it all because he want money then we
analyze his life we see first of all
what he lived in and he was basically a
room that was only six feet by 6 feet
yeah they had walls made of mud and palm
stalks and it had you know just a simple
ceiling that would sometimes
and it would and they had basically no
furniture just a mat and like a pillow
stuffed with palm fiber and a clay pot
another broken cup something like that
so now you don't see any wealth in his
life you see his wife Aisha are the low
on huh she used to say that sometimes
for two months there wouldn't be a fire
lit in his home so her cousin asked her
what did you eat how did you live she
said dates and water mean you just eat
dates which are sweet and drink water no
meat no bread nothing two months and
this is when he could have had money
this is one actually money was coming in
yeah but he would never came into his
house it was distributed immediately who
was he given to it was given to the poor
it was given put in the Muslim Treasury
but he never used it so much so to the
point that it almost caused a divorce
between him and his wives because they
were asking for an increase in stipend
or a salary and he refused and he caused
a big problem for him then this is now a
prophet who is also human and it has
problems like this but it shows you that
he refused to bring any money into his
home or even to give his wives they
lived a very difficult life so no food
no not no meat cooked in your home for
two months you know living in those
small cramped quarters if you want to
call them so every every way you look at
it you don't see wealth in his life you
see his teachings always telling people
to abstain from loving the materialism
to being attached to the worldly life so
this is not the teachings of someone who
wanted wealth yeah at the same time you
also see things like that he would get a
lot of wolf he would get near ten
thousand camels or or goats or sheep or
gold coins and he would give it all away
and come back all to the poor all to the
port and come home empty-handed yeah who
does that someone who is motive as money
that's not what they do and
interestingly when he first started his
message and I think you remember this
very well when he started his message
they came to him in and they said leave
this if it's money you want we'll give
you money if it's woman you want we'll
give you women so leave it so if his
motive was money he would have accepted
the offer kind of like when you come to
some of the corrupt people who are in
office the politician and they make the
side deal with the big corporation
exactly
this just vote this way exists and
that's when they crack and crumble so if
they came to him and said look if he
wanted money they came and said look
we'll give you money it was a kind of
this deal yeah but something else is
very interesting Eddie is that he was
actually very rich before becoming a
prophet and became poor after becoming a
profit so that goes against the plan if
he's gonna pretend to be a prophet to
make money yeah he should make money not
lose his money yeah so every way you
analyze his life you see that there was
nothing about wealth or love of money so
we got that one so you can X that off
fixed it out so the next one women
mm-hmm so you might argue with someone
might argue well he looked he wanted
women he pretend to be a prophet because
of woman and there we go yeah but every
way you analyze it you don't see that
the mark of a womanizer because first of
all when he first got married he was 25
years old but he married a woman who is
40 years old she is 15 years old she
proposed to him and she proposed to him
excellent now a womanizer womanizer
doesn't go for older woman yeah they go
for younger woman but he married the
woman that was 15 years older than him
he stayed married to her for a long
period of time for 15 years and never
married any other wife so a womanizer
again you know if he is making up his
own religion he'll say that I can marry
fifty or a hundred there yea or no limit
uh-huh but what him he remained with one
woman for 15 years who is older than him
that's not the mark of a womanizer yeah
his second marriage was to sew them into
zama narrations go from about her age
anywhere from the age 55 as high as 65
years of age if maybe it's a inaccurate
but that's high how high the narrations
go so the second wife was about fifty to
fifty some years old again that's not
how almond eyes or behaves yeah you go
younger you don't go old and this is his
wife not mistress exact girlfriend wife
this is wife yes and so every time you
start to look at one of the marriages of
the prophets of allah salem you will
find that some of them had a political
like not motive but like goal or like
wisdom behind them some of them had
social wisdoms behind them some have
religious rulings that were revealed
because of these marriages some of them
were humane like when he took soda or
galan who was an old woman she had
nowhere else to stay and he obviously
can't just bring her into his home so he
married her so some of them had two main
reasons behind them so there was always
a reason and it wasn't just that when
you look at it it's not the behavior of
someone who is a woman can it also be is
it a wisdom here because we see that we
have so much information on them now the
people behind the scenes are the wise so
they're narrating his his life is this
also a way now that to get more
information definitely and that's the
ultimate things the details of all his
life that the man can't give his buddies
his companions only the women can of
course and they lived with him and they
saw him do everything and so they were
able to relate to us the finest details
of his life yeah and by the way I mean n
no matter who you look at and you
analyze their life when you look at it
in detail you start to find flaws but we
have so much detail on the intimate life
of the process said lamp so if there was
a flaw would be able to see it very
clearly ya know and and an impostor
certain things would not work out like
the impostor would not practice what he
would preach right yeah I working who
can expound on that a bit more if you'd
like yeah let's take a break there's a
going and we'll be back an'desha there's
only former bad boy gone big boy well
with an entrepreneur and a man with an
icon in the music business how he
obtained something that money Christmas
unless we take a bit about all your
flight display hallo charlie successive
and records that I did he left that
light was in the country I couldn't go
through it look this good life was in
the country I couldn't go through the
life that brought him teach the perfect
person couldn't identify who I was or
the songs I create a chance
assistance get ready you're watching the
Dean show take it away Eddie what are
you waiting for what are we waiting for
right now what are you waiting for all
these people to come to this line what
are you waiting for what are we waiting
for right now when they're gonna come
they're gonna come to logon bring these
people lots of pot of water put in our
hand the ability to do it now do your
job back here Nadine show and we're
talking about the proofs and evidences
the arguments someone can have and we
listed a few of those money women power
and we knocked out the power you were
talking about the woman please continue
on yes so we're saying that when you
look at the the marriages of the process
headlamp they don't fit the pattern of
someone who is a womanizer not from age
not from duration because his first
marriage in the correction is that he
was married to his first wife for 25
years 25 yeah and the womanizer
basically doesn't need to stay with one
woman for a long time you know and I
think in our day and age most people are
familiar with how the womanizers yeah
operate okay so they don't stayed with
one for a long time so you can expound
on all these it can be a lecture on its
own absolute because we're almost out of
time tell us because we have a few more
that we have to knock out so this is and
I'm sure anyone who's sincere who has an
open my humble heart he can be like you
know what that makes sense yep so so if
you want to go ahead and wrap up on this
one and then we have a few more to cover
okay suppose he wanted power yeah right
if you wanted power he'd be demanding
power constantly right and he would be
elevating himself in status and this
religion and saying you know you know
like I'm flawless I don't make mistakes
you know bae everything that I say but
when you look at the message of the
Quran it actually puts him in a very
human-like a depiction you know that he
is human that he makes mistakes that he
will die just like everyone else dies
the thing about power suppose he wanted
power it's interesting how one time a
Bedouin Arab so like a nomadic Arab came
and he doesn't know what the Prophet
looks like soul asylum he hasn't seen
photographs there's no internet
magazines so he comes into the mosque of
the prophet saw said left and he has to
ask this question he has to say which of
you is Muhammad which is amazing that
means the Prophet SAW Salem was sitting
with his companion
dressed in a way like all of them were
addressed not dressed better or
differently not sitting on the throne or
sitting higher than they are and it
means he was so humble and so simple
that he looked just like anyone else so
he had to ask which of you is the
Prophet not like some men I mean who are
just constantly thriving for attention
now yeah when you go somewhere yes the
architecture of the room will tell you
how is that right yes you can't you
can't ever walk into a king's court and
then ask the Jester your highness it's
clothing clear the big chair the bigger
cloak the big head over it is amazing so
this is proof that it's nothing wanted
power even one time someone tells him
whatever Allah wills and you will and he
became angered he said have you made me
like an equal to allah ya say whatever
allah wills someone wanted power would
say yes yes absolutely you know
interestingly when the infant son of the
process Ellen passed away it coincided
with an eclipse yeah and when the
eclipse of the Sun so when the Sun
eclipsed at the moment the Sun the
infant of the process of them died the
people start to say you see the Sun is
sad at the death of the son of the
Prophet said yeah that son yeah so he
acts it now an imposter would take
advantage already right there solutely
yes and you should all be sad and
getting some way while you're at exactly
what did he do he says no these are son
these are like creations of Allah the
Sun and the moon and they don't you know
it's eclipsing or anything because of
the death or the life of anybody shied
away from the setting straight so you
can see it's not someone wanted power
throughout no power no power it's not if
you wanted to become famous then you
look at the Quran because the book the
Quran would have to be written by him
yeah so if he wanted a mole if there was
a motive it would be reflected in his
writing right so he would say you know
he would elevate himself in rank he
would say bring women to the Prophet
because he that's his motive yeah if you
wanted wealth he would write bring
wealth to the Prophet a God commanded to
bring him wealth if you wanted power he
would say obey everything that he does
blindly you know and so on and so forth
if he wanted like a Fame he would just
constantly talk about himself but
interestingly I know we're running out
of
I know Eddie but you know and you know
this that the name of Moses is mentioned
far more than the name of Muhammad SAW
said I'm in the Quran the name of jesus
is mentioned more than the name of
Muhammad fellow Salem so if you want to
be famous why is he writing about other
people in his book it's all about me the
book so every way you look at his life
it doesn't fit the mold of someone who
is an imposter pretending to be a
prophet to get some kind of worldly game
I'd like to earth people to do their own
research because everything about his
life is available online it's available
on the internet and books so you can
find and you look at it carefully does
this look like the act of an imposter
and you come to the clear conclusion
that it's not sure thank you very much
for being with us again look forward to
having you back here in the Dean show
God willing inshallah and thank you for
tuning in to another episode of the Dean
show we hope that you got to hear some
of the proofs and evidences and anybody
who comes out this with an open heart
and open mind and you're already seeking
the truth within your very self you're
seeking to want to know what the purpose
of life is why you're here and you're
wanting the guidance because if you're
not in the market then you know what
it's not going to fit it's not going to
work but if you are you can see that the
things that we're talking about not only
this show and all others other shows are
things that go with the good old common
sense and that's all we're asking you to
do to be sincere to ask the one who
created you for the guidance and to come
back here every week for another episode
of the Dean show don't forget to visit
our blog section at the Dean show com or
we also have now volume 2 of the dvds
for dawa along with the podcast and out
of audio versions of our shows and until
next time we'll see you God willing
inshaa allah assalamu alaikum peace be
unto you
oh he created the universe to him belong
the heavens and the earth l11 he is the
first he's the unearthly Ethan his
messengers to all his creatures on the
great danger of worshiping other than
Allah there is none greater
the creator